hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the Gray Eagle okay still don't know why
this is called the gray eagle but there
is a gray man hello not baby I don't
know why I was inclined to say that but
new sorry I do not swing that way anyway
we're walking down in the darkness like
we usually are oh well what the hell
this is something that I'm supposed to
do that I'm not seeing here hello hello
crow bar yes okay crow bar done and done
boom a crowbar broke hello I like a look
at you not saying you're ugly but you
wouldn't win no beauty contest kaboom
excuse me while I run away as fast as
possible
oh not a pit of doom I hate the pit of
doom no I don't want to go in the pit of
doom why is there a candle over there
usually the left side is the broken-down
side with nothing over here are you
telling me that there's something here
hello hello a cop there we go okay got
it
my super proneness will not allow me to
be stopped that early okay soon oh don't
know what Avenue zones 1 through 4 3 we
must have used a warp pipe
oh look good more dead bodies oh no wait
that's a statue okay and Fugees all
right so blue anything in the water
no I'm gonna climb up your body your
your body here and then we're gonna move
our Waker ah pisser yeah yeah I'm it how
in the baloney am I already out of oil
oh yeah that's because I wasted all of
it oh thank goodness
trying to find something that was right
in front of my face I swear that is not
25 percent good golly okay
carrying on this feels like something's
gonna jump out at me I just got this
weird yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty much
pretty much what I expected okay there's
a door blasted off its hinges in a blood
trail well let's go right in shall we
wait a minute what not why did it get
unnaturally dark there for just a split
second something went wonky dogs heads
was that glowing last bottle not
important loud Downham not really
important tinderbox
equally unimportant dead bodies man just
a whole bunch of fun times up in here
what's in here something that I need
nope just a leg okay let her on the
ground
Phillips dog is possessed by a demon
it is wild throws himself on the people
in issues a terrible sound now this
animals somewhere in the lower level I'm
scared
there's a doggy down here there's a
doggy somewhere down aha are you troll
are you son of a troll transporting node
I'm not about to run out of things
okay yeah why do you have so many tender
boxes but hardly any of these torches
can be lit you son of a [ __ ] okay I'm
yelling it imaginary people again
because I'm weird but then again you
guys all knew that right I am super
weird jump down
that's okay we got lots of loud down on
them did I scare anyone with my scream
okay I'm gonna try to make it you know
kind of rash in the oil a bit it's still
very dark hello dead rats squishy
squishy cheney way knees wheelie dealie
z' and nothing else
it gets like I swear it just randomly
gets unreasonably dark for no reason you
gonna I thought it was gonna be another
big giant head but apparently not okay
so something happen okay every time it
like it's yeah yeah good move there
[Music]
and the room with a dog can be something
useful I have to get there without
threat of death what what I mean
do I need to get some food for the
doggie there was a bunch of body parts
over in the up ok doggy I know you're
hungry I know you're hungry Munchie
Munchie Munchie Chomp Chomp Chomp
I'll get too many good delicious body
parts for you to munch on no I think I
could take one doggie pretty sure and
penumbra I just smashed doggies to bits
left and right there's one dog ain't no
man for me I'm too much man my to be
broken down by a doggie here okay sorry
sorry bro alright okay maybe he doesn't
want I bet he doesn't want the rotten
monster meat I bet he wants this fresh
bit of meat right here this nice
delicious leggy come here come here boy
I gotta look for you leggy lady leggy up
here yeah okay okay tirana me haha I
made it okay what's that spell no beef
yarn or wool of a man above yeah no okay
I summon the demon into your house
so good luck he's right behind you well
if he's not right now he will be
sometime later in the video you're
welcome
okay so now that I got this tasty human
leg diamond shovel
shut under the door too risky
what I have to leash tasty delicious leg
how do I get leg - you take the leg her
bud Thurber was there like another door
here that I can't see because it's too
damn dark ok so about that why is this
all greeny glowy why oxen the farmer
uses oxen I don't know what I'm supposed
to do how am I supposed to know maybe a
tasty delicious skull come on Shawn
boskie y'all know I summon the demon
into your house did you check check he's
there right behind you don't look now
Aris that'll really piss him off ok
so I can't seem to find what I'm
supposed to do here cuz I'm just a dumb
head so I'm going to go back and I needa
let's think he think with my brain
if the doggy doesn't want meat to eat
with his face hole maybe there's
something else that would make it quote
unquote safe safe for me to open the
door I do not know what could possibly
make it safe
there's a and two octagram thingy what
could make it safe
oh no that's like this wait a minute
this is above the dog you're right maybe
I could drop food down in a hole into
him or open up I'm so dumb I'm so dumb
let's try going backtracking a bit I
didn't find no hidden lever so y'all
can't yell at me y'all can't expect too
much of me because I am horrific lead um
there's some in the Wawa something in
the Wawa why is that green glow eNOS
ah-ha gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme yeah
sorry Brad sorry okay cool yeah all
right that would have been hard didn't
notice but see I used my brain and I
backtracked to area that I have already
been and it with will boost violated
beam and still behind you all right I
know it's probably getting problematic
now cannot use this way well how do I
use it why is it getting darker where do
I dammit doggy
I got your meat here don't you want your
meat don't you own your ding damn meat
maybe I could put it like here cuz this
is glowing aha
it makes sense and makes sense so I need
to like open it and run oh come on
well I'm uh oh I'm ho-ho and now I can't
put it down anymore is that what you're
doing to me oh okay oh oh oh I see oh I
see how that says oh oh I see oh I see
now I see how this is you worked before
but then I broke you somehow is that
what happened here I can't pick you up
and maybe now that I have picked you up
I dipped it in some green goop that the
dog you would get the doggy to move from
one room to another and now I can't Oh
what what I do I'm a doggie okay
that didn't make any sense at all I
don't know what I just dipped my meat in
you know what I mean but whatever
oh I dipped it in poison that's what oh
okay I thought it was just like
complimentary green glows
oh poor doggy doggy dead doggy
silvery did okay this rusty key is
obviously for the upstairs door to go to
the next zone which I will then use to
perpetrate my commitment to destroying
everything I see in my path you know
it's a pretty common theme in these
custom stories to notice it to notice
that no matter who you are you always
end up destroying everything that some
evil genius has worked for I mean I know
they're evil but come on they've worked
their whole life for this and you just
like stepped in for the past few minutes
and this aside I'm gonna [ __ ] up your
[ __ ] and then they are really sad so
don't mess with evil geniuses evil plots
uh
douche gay
it's still dark could you know piss yes
son of a [ __ ] ow
hello who is out there who is evil train
man come to take me away I don't even
remember there being a train track in
the first amnesia I don't think I was
supposed to be down here I think I'm
supposed to be up there hello can't go
in there alrighty then how about over
here
there we go we got a winner then some
big doors Oh
shakey jiggy jiggy I guess I shouldn't
have expected it considering it as a me
yeah that a big train would goddamnit
okay re I thought that actually locked
on me excuse me pardon me comin through
okay so we got an insert boxy thing here
man it does not want to give me any
light oh damn dark whole thing just too
damn dark get out my way okay let's go
down this other path now hello no I
can't turn this why not it is stuck does
it need some persuading no can i light
this candle thank you that's not very
much seriously the darkness it's not
good for my eyes not good for my skin
either my delicate complexion okay so
I'm at a loss
I need a disc thingy the foggy - button
the thing and then crank it and then
you've really rub it out and squirted
all over and well is that talking about
I had no idea oh god I got lost first
thing there aha
is there a way up and I was supposed to
go here some whoa see look at that why
you get dark all the Sonic just dips to
blackness like the light exchange thing
doesn't seem to work quite right
rope aha I must have missed this one
before
excuse me shovel do you have something
to say that's right uh-huh okay so I'm
all out of time for this one so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean okay